i think you're probably reasonably
familiar with the idea of a square root
but i want to clarify some of the
notation that at least i always found a
little bit ambiguous at first i want to
make it very clear in your head so when
i write
if i write
a
9 under a radical sign i think you know
you'll read this as the square root of 9
but i want to make one clarification
when you just see a number under a
radical sign like this
this means
this means the principle
principle
square
root
of
9. and when i say the principle square
root i'm really saying the positive
square root of nine
so this this
statement right here is equal to
three and i'm being clear here because
you might already know that nine has two
actual square roots nine also
by definition square root is something
squ if that a square root of nine is a
number that if you square it equals nine
three is a square root but so is
negative three
negative three also
a square
root
but if you just write a radical sign
you're actually referring to the
positive square root or the principal
square root if you want to refer to the
negative square root you would actually
put a negative in front of the radical
sign that is equal to
negative 3 or if you want to refer to
both the positive and the negative both
the principal and the negative square
roots you'll write a plus or minus sign
you'll write a plus or minus sign in
front of the radical sign and of course
that's equal to
plus or
minus 3 right there so with that out of
the way what i want to talk about is the
graph
is the graph of the function
y is equal to the principal square root
of x and see how it relates to
the function
y
is equal to
x let me write it over here because i'll
work on it see how it relates to
y
is equal to x squared and then if we
have some time we'll shift them around a
little bit and get a better
understanding of how these
what causes these functions to shift up
down or or left and right so let's make
a little
value table before we get out our
graphing calculator
so this is for y is equal to x squared
so we have x and y values and this is y
is equal to the square root of x once
again we have x
and
y values right there so let me just pick
some
arbitrary x values right here and i'll
stay in the positive x domain
so let's say x is equal to 0
1
let me stay make it color coded when x
is equal to 0 what's y going to be equal
to well y is x squared so 0 squared is
0.
when x is 1 y is 1 squared which is 1.
when x is 2
y is 2 squared which is 4
when x is 3
when x is 3 y is 3 squared which is 9.
we've seen this before and i could keep
going maybe i'll add a little let me add
4 here so when x is 4 y is 4 squared or
16. we've seen all of this we've graphed
our parabolas this is all a bit of
review
now let's see what happens when y is
equal to the principal square root of x
let's see what happens i'm going to pick
some x values on purpose just to make it
interesting when x is equal to 0 what's
y going to be equal to the principle
square root of 0 what's 0
0 squared is 0. when x is equal to 1 the
principal square root of x of 1 is just
positive 1. it has another square root
that's negative 1 but we don't we don't
have a positive or negative written here
we just have the principal square root
when x is a 4
what is y
well the principle square root of 4 is
positive 2.
when x is equal to 9 what's y
when x is equal to 9 the principal
square root of 9 is 3. finally when x is
equal to 16 principle square root of 16
is 4. so i think you already see how
these two are related we've essentially
just swapped the x's and the y's right
you have well these are the same x and
y's but here you have x is 2 y is 4.
here x is 4 y is 2. 3 comma 9 9 comma 3
4 comma 16 16 comma 4. and that makes
complete sense if you were to square
both sides of this equation if you were
to square both sides of this equation
you would get
y squared is equal to
x right there and of course you would
want to restrict the domain of y to
positive y's because
this can only take on positive values
because this is the principle square
root but the general idea of we just
swapped the x's and y's between this
function and this function right here if
you assume a domain of positive x's and
positive y's
now let's see what the graphs look like
and i think you might already have a a
guess of what let me let me just graph
them here let me do them by hand because
i think that's instructive sometimes
before you take out the graphing
calculator so i'm just going to stay in
the positive
in the first quadrant here in the first
quadrant so let me graph
this first so we have the point zero
zero the point one comma one
the point two
comma two
which i'm gonna have to do it a little
bit smaller than that let me mark
this is one two three
actually let me do it like this let me
go
one two three four five six seven eight
nine 10 11 12 13 14 15 16
that's about how far i have to go and
have
one two three four five six seven eight
nine 10 11 12 13 14 15 16
that's about how far i have to go in
that direction as well now let's graph
it so we have 0 0
1 1
2
1 2 3 4
2 comma 4
right there 3 comma 9 3
5 6 7 8 9.
3 comma 9 is right about there
and then we have 4 comma 16. 4 comma 16
is going to be right
right above there so the graph of y is
equal to x squared we've seen this
before
it's going to look something like this
we're just graphing it in the positive
quadrant so we get this upward opening u
just like that
just like that
now let's graph y is equal to the
principal square root of x
so here we have once again we have 0 0
we have 1 comma 1 we have 4 comma 2 1 2
3 4
comma 2
we have 9 comma 3 5 6 7 8 9 comma
3
right about there and we have 16 comma 4
16 comma 4 is right about there so this
graph
looks like
that
so notice they look they look like
they're kind of flipped around the axes
this one opens along the y-axis this one
opens along the x-axis and once again it
makes complete sense because we've
swapped the x's and the y's especially
if you just consider the first quadrant
and actually these are
symmetric around the line y is equal to
x and we'll talk about things like
inverses in the future that are
symmetric around the line y is equal to
x and we can graph this better on a
regular graphing calculator i found this
on the web i just did a quick web search
i want to give proper credit to the
people i'm
whose resource i'm using so this is
my.hrw.com
math06 you could pause this video and i
hopefully you should be able to read
this especially if you're looking at an
hd but let's graph these different
things let's graph it a little bit
cleaner than what i can do by hand and
actually let me
have some of what i wrote there
so that should give you
that should give you okay so let's first
just graph y is equal to
y is equal to x squared
and then in green let me graph y is
equal to the square root of
x
i have some buttons here on the right
just so you know what i'm doing i have
some buttons here on the right squared
and the radical sign and all of that
but i want you to let me just focus on
this
so let me just graph those
so first i did x squared and then it did
the square root of x and look when if
you just focus on the first quadrant
right here you see that you get the
exact same result that i got
over there although mine is messier
now just for fun and you know i really
didn't do this yet with the regular
quadratics let's see what happens what
we need to do to shift the different
graphs
so with x squared well i'm going to do
two things i'm going to scale the graphs
and i'm going to shift them
so that's x squared so let's just focus
on the x squared and see what happens
when we scale it and then i'll do it
with the radical sign as well because i
want to get this this will really work
for anything let's see what happens when
you get 2
times
2 times
not not 2 squared 2 times
x squared and let's do another one that
is 1.5
0.5 times
our point
i could just do 0.4 actually 0.45 times
x
squared let's graph these right there
so x squared so notice our regular x
squared is just in red if we scale it by
2 it's still a parabola with the vertex
at the same place but we go up faster in
both directions and if we have 0.5 times
x squared we still have a parabola but
we go up a little bit slower we have a
wider we have a wider opening u because
our scaling factor is lower than one so
that's how you kind of
decide how wide or how narrow the
opening of our parabola is and then if
you want to shift it to the left or the
right and i want you to think about why
this is so that's x squared let's say i
want to just take the graph of x squared
and i want to shift it 4 to the right
what i do is i say x minus 4
x minus 4 squared and if i want to shift
it 2 to the let's say i want to shift it
2 to the left x plus 2
squared
what do we get
notice it did exactly what i said x
minus 4 squared was shifted 4 to the
right x plus 2 squared was shifted 2 to
the left and it might be unintuitive at
first this shifting that i'm talking
about but really think about what's
happening over here the vertex is where
x is equal to 0 when you get 0 squared
up here now over here the vertex is when
x is equal to 4 but when x is equal to 4
you stick 4 in here you get 4 minus 4 so
you're still squaring 0 right 4 minus 4
is 0 and that's what you're squaring
over here
when you when x is equal to negative 2
negative 2 plus 2 you are squaring 0. so
if in other words whatever you're
squaring that at 0 is equivalent to 4
here or 4 is equivalent to 0 and
negative 2 is equivalent to 0 over there
so i want you to think about it a little
bit another way you could think about it
when x is equal to 1 we're at this point
of the red parabola but when x is equal
to 5 on the green parabola you have 5
minus 4 inside of the
parentheses you have a 1 just like x is
equal to 1 over here up here so you're
at the same point in the parabola so i
want you to think about that a little
bit it might be a little non-intuitive
that you should you say minus 4 to shift
to the right and plus 2 to shift to the
left but it actually makes a lot of
sense
now the other interesting thing is to
shift things up and down and that's
actually pretty straightforward you want
to shift this curve up let's say you
want to shift the red curve up a little
bit you do x squared plus one
notice it got shifted up if you want
this green curve to be shifted down by
five you put a minus five right there
and then
you graph it and got shifted down by
five if you want it to be
open up a little wider than that maybe
scale it down a little bit scale it down
let's say 0.5 times that
so now the green
curve will be scaled down and it opens
slower it has a wider opening and the
same idea can be done with the
a principal square root so let me do
that
let me do the same idea and the same
idea actually can be done with any
function
so let's do the square root of x
and let's in green let's do the square
root of x
let's say minus five so we're shifting
it over to the right by five
and then let's have the square root of
x plus
four so we're gonna shift it to the left
by 4 and let's shift it down by 3. and
so let's graph all of these
so the square root of x then the square
root of x minus 5 notice it's the exact
thing same thing as the square root of x
but i shifted it to the right by five
when x is equal to five i have a zero
under the radical sign same thing as
square root of zero so this point is
equivalent to that point now when i have
the square root of x plus four i've
shifted it over the left by 4 when x is
negative 4 i have a 0 under the radical
sign so this point is equivalent to that
point and then i subtracted 3 which also
shifted it down 3. so this is my
starting point if i want this blue
square root to open up slower
if i want it to open up slower so it'll
be a little bit narrower i would scale
it down
so here putting a low number will scale
it down and make it more narrow because
we're opening along the x-axis
so let me do that and let me make let me
make this green one let me open up wider
so let me say it's three times
the square root of x minus five so let's
graph all of these
so notice this blue one is now opens up
more narrow and this green one now opens
up a lot i guess you could say a lot
faster it scaled up then we could shift
that one up a little bit by four
and then we graph it and there you go
and notice that we don't have when we
graph these it's not a sideways parabola
because we're talking about the
principle square root and if you did the
plus or minus square root it actually
wouldn't even be a valid function
because you would have two y values for
every x value so that's why we have to
just use the principal square root
anyway hopefully you found this little
a talk i guess about the relationships
with x of with parabolas and uh or with
the x squareds and the principal square
roots useful and how to shift them and
that'll actually be really useful in the
future when we talk about inverses and
and shifting functions